Optimization view modes are a really powerful way to get a visualization of
what your scene is doing at any given view type and really powerful to help
support you in your quest for getting optimization. So you can find these
different view modes from your viewport. You can change the drop-down
from the lit model and change the view mode. There's many many different
types that you can pick which we'll cover a few of the the more common
ones here today but it's definitely worth playing around with all the
different view modes. So again in your viewport where you might see lit or
unlit, the button there at the top of your main viewport, you can
go through the the modes there. So light complexity is quite useful for
knowing how much resource is being used by the lights. This is
especially going to be predominant if you've got a dynamically lit scene for
example or you've got a lot of dynamic lights in your scene when you want the
majority of it to be just statically rendered. So an ideal light complexity is
this black to dark blue. As soon as it starts getting to green and orangey red
we start getting a little bit more expensive as soon as your scene starts
growing purpley pink a lilac color or white that means like white gets
it's almost like white hot in terms of lighting complexity. You really want
to try and avoid that. That can be caused when there's a lot of dynamic
lights overlapping each other. So yeah lighting will have a big impact
especially if you're deciding on you know the use of real-time global
illumination with lumen or something or whether you want statically baked
scene. Again it depends on the project, it depends on the desired platform, what
can be supported but light complexity is a very useful thing to be able to view
here. We can also view Nanite in the scene as well. So when we look at Nanite
we can see the instances, we can see the different primitives that are used, we
can see the different materials that are used, any overdraw that's going on. So
when we're referring previously to the overdraw of meshes what is unreal
taking a few different passes on rendering. So overdraw can be caused when
it's trying to render something at a distance. So it renders the scene once,
it's like right I've not got everything, it renders it again, it renders it again
and how many times it needs to render that frame can cause
overdraw. And then you've also got different masks and this is just a
really useful pre-visualization of your Nanite here. And then when
we're talking about Nanite overdraw you want to see these kind of darker
patches in the Nanite overdraw. As soon as it starts getting more layered in its
approach and starts turning a bit more orangey there that's where it gets very
expensive. So the expense starts when the color starts creeping in with the
orange, as soon as you start getting brighter oranges almost like getting
shades of white in there that's where it gets very expensive.